début mai un sommet quoi terminer qu'il
tombe sur la tête c'est une partie de ma
vie personnelle qui ne tient pas c'est
sur le trajet d'un coup tu te retrouves
sans festival mais avec quand même un
des dates d'un festival tu étais un peu
dévasté impression que c'est injuste
ils sont réalisateur documentariste
distributeurs directeur de festival
ils ont travaillé pendant des mois voire
des années pour offrir au public une
oeuvre ou un événement mais la pandémie
a changé la donne les salles de cinéma
sont fermées des festivals france formée
après l'émotion restait une question à
laquelle ils ont dû trouver des réponses
comment rejoindre leur public
on comprendre comment le cinéma s'est
adapté depuis le début de la pandémie
on a voulu commencer avec ce qui est
généralement la première étape dans la
vie d'un film à savoir les festivals et
pour ceux qui les organisent
ils ont dû faire rapidement leur deuil
pour proposer des alternatives à leur
événement en personne une alternative
qui est souvent en ligne aient eu besoin
de ça n'aurait fait aucun sens de
géolocaliser l'événement parce que m6
n'est pas un festival français
ensuite il ya toute la question de la
dimension ne voulait pas tuer non plus
la carrière du film en les rendant
accessibles à tous librement
ce qui fait que le festival n'est
accessible qu'aux accréditer les
accréditations seront très abordable et
on limite cela vingt mille accrédités
mais outre la rencontre avec son public
les festivals sont aussi des tremplins
dans la carrière des cinéastes hills
estivales sont là aussi pour créer des
opportunités de travail puis de
rencontre de collaboration avec un pour
moi c'était l'opportunité de pitch est
mon prochain projet de lever des fonds
pour les prochains projets et et deux
doigts de profiter de visibilité pour
penser déjà à la suite et ça je n'ai pas
eu cette dimension de réseautage c'est
la plus complexe c'est celle qui va
souffrir le plus et même là les
festivals comme les distributeurs ont dû
proposer des initiatives pour remplacer
à la fois la rencontre avec le public
mais aussi les échanges professionnels
qui caractérise ces rendez vous en êtes
en train de bâtir du matériel vidéo dès
qu on n ait des questions réponses avec
les cinéastes entrevue soir alors certes
les cinéastes reconnaissent que ce ne
sera pas pareil
juste pour vous mettre en contexte
quartier une projection en fait les gens
se mettent à lancer des avions en papier
les gens crient les jean-claude is la
salle et ils demandent donc prêt dans
une salle de cinéma propose un geste de
privation de liberté dans s'installe en
vue dans un environnement noir et on n'a
rien d'autre pour attirer notre
attention que que ce qu'il ya sur
l'écran il sait ce geste c'est acte de
foi là on ne le fait pas quand on
regarde sur un écran d'ordinateur on ne
fait pas quand on regarde sur un écran
télévision chez soi mais dans les
circonstances actuelles tous ont tenu à
relativiser la situation et même à
trouver du positif dans tous ces
bouleversements
c'est une dualité qui qui est
intéressante parce que à la fois on veut
donner ce moment le signal
on sait à quel point c'est important
parce que ça fait partie du la rampe de
lancement
en même temps quand on fume disponible
en ligne voir si ça permet à des gens
qui l'auraient jamais vu ça nous oblige
à prendre hong kong le monde virtuel
qu'on a tous un peu négligé même sans
revenir à 3 fois
je pense que certaines choses qui vont
nous amener des iem du mode de
fonctionnement plus démocratique pour
les cimes un milieu qui conserva pas
qu'ils quitteraient qui suit les règles
sauf que ça décloisonner nul
certes on ne remplacera pas les grands
écrans les rencontres entre les
cinéastes et leur public
mais pour beaucoup le cinéma trouvera
toujours des façons de rejoindre son
audience et les nouveaux formats qui
émerge pourrait même permettre de le
rendre encore plus accessible si bien
que les festivals les distributeurs les
salles de cinéma pourraient conserver
certains changements imposés par la
pandémie
kate